[Music]
hello
oh
what are you doing here i got called to
the principal's office
so did i
would you do something wrong
not that i'm aware of
did you
oh no
[Music]
maybe it's good news
sheldon you ever been called the
principal's office for good news never
gentlemen good news i had a feeling
what's up we got the psat results back
and sheldon
got a perfect score
neat thanks tom i'll be sure to put that
up on the fridge no you don't understand
children's the only kid in the school to
ever do this at his age maybe in the
whole country it was fun i enjoyed it
so what's this mean it means he pitched
a perfect game george i've already
gotten calls from colleges who want to
meet him for like scholarships and stuff
for everything they might even pay you
to get him
my man
when was the last time you washed your
hands come on
can you believe it perfect school
good job moonpie and not just that
college is already sniffing around to
recruit him what do you mean colleges
he's 10. principal peterson said caltech
is interested where's caltech
california mom california it has cow
right there in the name you're not a
part of this conversation
the tech is for technology shelly go to
your room the adults need to talk
given the events of the day i would
argue i am an adult and should be
treated as one
probably could have said that
differently
[Music]
you honestly think that little boy is
ready for college hey i don't think he
was ready for high school but here we
are a year and a half in and no one got
hurt that is different he's got you and
georgie over there and he's still living
at home with his mother and his sister
and me
sure i understand all that then why are
you pushing so hard for this because
these schools are interested now it's
like football recruiting you got to
strike while the iron's hot this is
nothing like football oh yeah what if he
stops being smart and they don't want
him anymore how is that gonna happen
i don't know
klunk's head
will you help me please sorry i'm not a
part of this
[Music]
conversation at least dad's on my side
doesn't matter mom's gonna win she
always does but i have to leave for
college at some point if you went to
college you know what would happen i'd
enjoy higher learning
you would die you would curl up on the
floor and die that's not true you can't
even take care of your own boo-boos for
your information every college is
staffed with a medical professional my
boo-boos will be well-tended to
sheldon come back in here
i guess we'll find out what happened i
already know what happened mom won
well
shelly i am very proud of you for doing
so well on that test
but you can't go off to college mom in a
few years sure but right now you can
just keep taking your one college class
with dr sturgis
why can't i go there full-time oh baby
it's an hour away we can't drive you
back and forth every day i'm the one
who's been driving him and she loves it
how can he be so smart and so clueless
at the same time
dr sturgis lives at the school what if
he acted as my guardian that's an idea a
crazy one but it would only be on school
nights shelly what's the point of being
intelligent if i can't take advantage of
opportunities like this
[Music]
they're still discussing
mom didn't win it's touch and go crazy
let the truth be